in raising a question that I'm going to
be talking to you A lot of people
brought up this topic probably because
Eric Weinstein talked to Joe Rogan
recently and said that he and you were
contacted by folks about UFOs uh can you
clarify the nature of this contact
yeah yeah that you will contact about
I've got very little to say on this I
mean he has much more to say I think he
I think he went down
this Rabbit Hole further than than I did
um
which wouldn't surprise anyone
he's got much more of a taste for this
sort of thing than I do but I think
we're contacted by the same person
it wasn't clear to me who this person
was or how this person got that my cell
phone number
um
they didn't seem
uh it didn't seem like we were getting
punked I mean the person seemed credible
to me and they were talking to you about
the release of different videos on you
yeah and this this is when there was a
flurry of activity around this so there
was like it was a big New Yorker article
on on UFOs and there was there was a
the rumors of Congressional hearings I
think come in and
if and then with the the videos that
were being debunked or not
um
and so this person contacted both of us
I think around the same time and I think
he might have contacted Rogan or other
Eric is just the only person I've spoken
to about it I think
um who I know was contacted and
the um
what happened is the person kept you
know writing a check that he didn't cash
like he kept saying okay next week I'm
gonna you know I understand this is
sounding spooky and you know you have no
reason to really trust me but uh next
week I'm gonna I'm gonna put you on a
zoom call with people who you will
recognize and they're going to be you
know former heads of the CIA and you
know people people who just you're gonna
within five seconds of being on the zoom
call you'll you'll know this is not a
hoax uh so great just let me know just
send me the zoom link right and I went
that happened maybe three times you know
it was just one phone conversation and
then it was just texts you know there's
just a bunch of texts and I think uh
Eric spent more time with this person
and I'm not I haven't spoken about it I
know he spoke about it publicly but
um
so I you know it's not that my
detector ever
really went off in a big way is just the
thing never happened and I so I lost
interest